I'm gonna take one strand of hair and
put it just out of place for everybody
who bitched about it my blade runner'
2049 review there you go yeah that'll
drive him nuts one it the mountain
between us so the mountain between the
stars Kate Winslet and Idris Elba they
meet in an airport they both need to get
somewhere but their flights were
compromised so they're getting this
little charter plane and of course it
crash lands in the mountains in the
middle of nowhere so we have a nature
versus nurture movie a survival film
which is funny because when I was going
into this movie I was like the title the
mountain between us sounds like a
romance aside from the person who
brought you the notebook comes down
mountain between us survival which is
actually a romance I am saving you from
the bait-and-switch that the trailer set
you up for that's not a bad thing you
can have a survival film that is also a
romance movie castaway the romance
between a man in his volleyball and it
worked thing about this movie is though
the cast is strong Idris Elba and Kate
Winslet both talented the movie tries to
be two things that never actually form
into one cohesive film I didn't feel
they had the chemistry the movie wanted
us to believe they had together they
both did fine for the survival aspect of
the film right when they crash-landed
about three days fly by in no time I was
like this might be choppy and sure
enough there's no real way to tell how
much time they were out there until she
actually addresses how much time they
were out there you're like oh my god
Idris Elba's been out there for that
long and he has the ability to trim the
top of his beard still amazing there's
awkward humor in the movie that doesn't
really work I mean sometimes it does
work sometimes it's charming and
endearing a lot of the time though just
fell flat this movie has a formula to it
a very simple formula they get into an
argument with each other they get
irritated then they make up and they
move along then they stop to rest and
they get into an argument with each
other and just rinse and repeat the
first time interest Elba kind of snaps
at Kate Winslet there's no real build-up
to it and I believe they were there in
one confined space for quite a while but
the movie doesn't actually properly
address time and how long they've been
there so it just looks like he snaps at
her and he looks like a dick go in his
situation maybe any of us would do the
same thing then the wrap-up is happening
and the movie just keeps going on it was
the Return of the King ending man - the
12 hour epic preceding it movie loses me
in the small details everything from the
fact that neither of them really packed
gear for snow because they were just
going
one Airport to the other and although
I'll buy the fact that maybe there was
some gear in the plane no one lost any
toes and I find that strange this when I
was a kid and I would wear boots made
for snow and my feet would freeze after
about a half an hour of playing in the
snow say nothing for walking chest deep
in the stuff in the mountain then the
movie just wraps up and you're like
alright I'm probably not gonna remember
this movie in t-minus one day ya already
forgot all right guys are the mountain
between us have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your favorite
survival movie mankind versus nature
nature versus nurture whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]